so you wait until they already dying
before
you this is not what I said one one more
time again you're trying to you know
misund understand what you
want what I said no I actually I
actually purposely made it exaggerated
it but the point stands the point is
what you're saying is you're going to
wait until there's a health issue before
you bring it up but the reality is what
you should do as a friend is to bring it
up because the reality is some people
don't even know yeah what's going on
when it could be when something could be
going wrong with them but if you bring
it up then they could look like okay
maybe I should go to the hospital and
actually check myself on